prince philip husband of queen elizabeth
ii
has died
[Music]
the british public i think have a very
strong
affection for the duke of edinburgh in
2009 he became
the longest-serving british consort or
companion to the sovereign he's been an
amazing consort
to the queen he's never further than a
few paces behind her
he's um he's not shy in the way that the
queen is often shy
he he seems to connect with people he's
always happy to make a joke
and he has a great skill of making
people feel at ease
but after suffering a number of serious
health ailments in recent years
from kidney infections to a stomach
operation back in 2013
to a stent that was put into his chest
the duke of edinburgh with full support
from the queen
decided to step down from public duties
in may
2017. we've got the oldest monarch ever
to have reigned
we're not used to hearing about our
royals retiring but we're not used to
our royals
living as long as the windsors we are in
slightly uncharted territory
world's most experienced pluck on there
while philip continued to appear at a
handful of events
including prince harry and meghan
markle's royal wedding
in may 2018 and princess eugenie's
nuptials to jack brooksbank that october
the royals spent most of his final years
laying low
splitting his time between scotland's
balmoral castle
and windsor castle in the english
countryside where he was occasionally
spotted
attending church services or driving
around the grounds with his wife the
queen
he's been loyal he's been a constant
companion someone who the queen will
always turn to before she makes
an important decision when she first met
prince philip he um
he was a young naval officer and she
fell deeply in love with him
at the time uh her father was not sure
of the
of the union but um the queen was
absolutely determined that um that
philip was the one
the royal couple who celebrated their
72nd wedding anniversary in november
2019
said i do at london's westminster abbey
in 1947.
the same place prince william and kate
middleton tied the knot in 2011.
elizabeth was only 21 at the time philip
was 26.
they are you know the most lovely couple
and
i i hope catherine and i have the same
sort of future ahead of us
philip and elizabeth went on to have
four children in total
but only prince charles and princess
anne were born before a then
25 year old elizabeth inherited the
throne
after her father king george vi died of
cancer
in 1952. philip knelt an homage to his
wife during the 1953
coronation ceremony as he assumed his
new role
consort to the queen
[Music]